many of us have been living with vaccine
mandates for months and they're not
going anywhere anytime soon the
mandate's kicking in across the country
starting today you'll need one of these
a vaccine card people will soon be
required to show proof of full
vaccination to do most indoor activity
so far most vaccine orders issued by
cities and states have been upheld with
judges citing a supreme court precedent
set more than a century ago when it
ruled on a state's smallpox vaccine
mandate but now cases involving the
federal government's power to mandate
vaccines are before the supreme court
and they could ultimately help decide
who has the power to order shots in arms
so here's what you need to know about
the legal precedent for vaccine mandates
in america and what the supreme court is
looking at now
back in 1905 the issue of vaccine
mandates reached the supreme court when
a lutheran pastor named henning jacobson
refused to get a government-mandated
smallpox vaccine in part because he said
he had suffered seriously from previous
vaccination he sued the state claiming
that the vaccine was dangerous and that
healthy law-abiding people like himself
didn't pose a danger to the community
but the supreme court ruled against him
writing for the majority justice john
marshall harlan stated the liberty
secured by the constitution does not
import an absolute right in each person
to be wholly freed from restraint there
are manifold restraints to which every
person is necessarily subject for the
common good in other words personal
freedom can be limited particularly when
it threatens the community since then
authorities have long implemented public
health mandates to try to keep
communities safe fast forward to today
and the coronavirus pandemic since
coveted vaccines became widely available
last year more than 20 states and dozens
of cities have adopted vaccine mandates
and those mandates have largely been
upheld by judges appointed by
republicans and democrats alike many
citing jacobson the federal government
has also ordered vaccines for a wide
range of people like federal workers and
health care workers who treat patients
on medicare and medicaid and through the
occupational safety and health
administration or osha the
administration ordered all businesses
with more than 100 employees to ensure
that their workers are either vaccinated
or tested weekly we've been patient
but our patients is wearing thin
with the federal government taking an
assertive role dozens of states business
groups and religious groups sued to
block the mandates they argue that osha
which is tasked with ensuring safe
working conditions and the centers for
medicare and medicaid services which
oversees government health insurance
programs don't have the authority to
issue such mandates under federal law
with vaccination deadlines looming for
businesses and health care workers and
with legal challenges mounting the
supreme court agreed to weigh in with
fast-track arguments we will hear
argument first this morning in
application
21a 244. the liberal justices appeared
to support the government's order and at
one point there was a back and forth
about the state's power to police public
health power that was affirmed by the
jacobson case if it's within the police
power to protect the health and welfare
of workers
you seem to be saying the states can do
it but you're saying the federal
government can't
even though it's facing
the same crisis in interstate commerce
that states are facing within their own
borders
i am not sure i understand the
distinction the federal government has
no police power oh it does have power
with respect to protecting the health
and safety
of workers but many of the conservative
justices expressed skepticism about the
federal government's power it seems to
me that the more and more
mandates that pop up in different
agencies it's fair i wonder if it's not
fair for us to look at the court as a
general exercise of power by the federal
government and then ask the questions of
well why isn't congress have a say in
this and why don't this why doesn't this
be the primary responsibility of the
states the court is expected to come to
a decision on whether the biden mandates
can be enforced in the coming weeks to
understand what that could mean for
millions of americans let's call my
colleague brent kendall he covers the
supreme court for wsj hi shelby hey
brent he says that even though the cases
are being heard on a fast-track basis
the supreme court's decisions could have
lasting implications for now the court
doesn't even have to say with finality
whether what the biden administration is
doing is is lawful or not it just has to
decide if it's likely lawful okay so
even though they're not ruling on the
merits necessarily it will determine the
fate of the mandates it will i mean the
merits is part of this consideration
even though they don't have to issue a
full merits ruling if they don't want to
i think it's likely for all practical
purposes that what the supreme court
says here will end this some law
professors point out that the
conservative leaning court has not been
a fan of expansive federal regulation
instead preferring to defer to the
states for example it blocked the biden
administration's eviction moratorium in
august in our constitutional system the
way things are set up is that you know
the federal government has limited power
so states are typically the first line
of defense for deciding how best to
protect health within their borders
brent says a big question is whether the
federal government can overrule states
particularly those that don't want to
implement the vaccine mandates the
supreme court's ruling on the biden
mandates might decide the fate of the
mandates themselves but it's unlikely
it'll move the needle much in terms of
the public debate over vaccines after
all jacobson lost his case more than a
century ago yet many still hold his same
beliefs about individual liberties and
the right to remain unvaccinated so keep
your eye on wsj.com for news of the
court's ruling and if you thought this
video was interesting be sure to
subscribe to the channel so you can
follow me as i cover more news that's
impacting our lives see you next time
[Music]